combien de vieux courriels qui ne
servent à rien traîne dans votre
messagerie si vous pensez que l'espace
virtuel est infini descendez de votre
nuage la réalité c'est que nos données
remplissent des millions de serveurs
énergivores il faut quand même dire que
l'essentiel de la pollution numérique
vient de la fabrication de nos appareils
mais quand on archive télécharge
visionne partage on pollue aussi de
petits gestes peuvent réduire notre
impact par exemple envoyer un texto
consomme moins qu'envoyer un courriel
accédez directement à un site en tapant
son adresse pollue quatre fois moins
qu'utiliser un moteur de recherche vous
pouvez aussi fermer tous ces onglets
inutilisés désactivez la lecture
automatique des vidéos sur les réseaux
sociaux diminuer la définition de
l'image quand vous vous servez d'un
petit écran sans oublier de faire un peu
de ménage dans vos courriels et pelleter
une partie de votre nuage sur un disque
dur
pas seulement